they put me in a
car dark you can't see anything car is
going around and there and left and
right and i don't know where's
we going in the end i was in front of
palace shaped
the door like an eagle
and here i went inside and
somebody come to me and stay here one
second service
okay uh
the other doors open are they
in front of me
uh how are you my friend
how you keeping this is a saddam sun
that's in front of you
yeah okay and i look at him and
i say i'm good they say well done what
you doing you have a few medals now and
you're a good fighter and all these
reports coming about you
on this and that and sit down and
you bring a cigar for me and
he just clicked something and orange
juice coming and fruit on the table and
does
oh it's a long old days and start
talking
and i say to make it short to you
what about you become saddam's son
and i smiled and i said to him we are
all saddam sons
you know and he like we are all saddam
sons
they say no i want to be
your real saddam son you i wanted to be
my feed i
feed i sacrified
yourself or somebody else
when i try to play
stupid or idiot and i say what do you
mean bodyguard security he say no
i want you to be all day
um they start explaining to me and like
that
but the picture in my head
my dad my mother my sisters my
brothers baghdad iraq everything is
going in my head
and the report coming from intelligence
service they say you look like me
and hahaha this he's talking
and i'll say any choice he said to me
yeah sure we have choice we are in a
free country you can say what you want
to say
and if you review i say
if i say yes what happened if i say no
what's happened
they say to me if you say yes
you'll be okay my power
everything is you if you say no
i shake hand with you and you go to your
army and finish
i say great i say oh they we are
you know friends and
you know i'm in the army and you know we
are just another
year or how long got to be i finish i go
with my business
and my dad business and like that and
before even i finished
i see his eyes just like start fire out
of it
and they say this mean
you're refusing i say you give me the
choice and i'm saying to you was a glass
of
juice in my hand he kept him
somebody come and take my ring out
uh folding my eye
my head is down
push me to the boot of the car not even
in the car
and the boot of the car driving around
like that kick me from the boot
your head down down down open a
door and they pushed me
straight away i was to the wall
they took that's what they covered my
eyes with
everything is red light
walk floor door
everything is red painted red
no window no nothing you can't see the
time in it and they should be down it's
one meter by one meter even
you can't sit or you know not
comfortable
and not well yet no nothing this little
hole in the floor and that's it
i don't know how long i spend exactly
but
i was counted six seven days
because even with that they was confuse
me they give me for example and the
breakfast they give me dinner and
dinner they give me breakfast and
you know just to don't know where you
are what time
the day or night
but you know it's not well yet the smell
you know psychologically after i learned
after i learned this is more
psychologically work coming from russian
or
sovereign union intelligence service
what they was
training the iraqi intelligence service
for that but called
psychologically war
here what six seven days the door is
open
was a day
and was another guy with him what he
live in jordan
now and he said to me
did you change your mind now or do you
want me to bring your sisters here
and you know what this mean
i say no please i do anything you want
leave my family alone
he said okay i was living you know
seven days same clothes dirty and like
this he said come out
i come out they didn't hold my eye they
didn't do anything to me
i come out i saw myself
this is the palace you know of
and they have a special prison for
really serious people they hate them
anyway he took me
to the car and drove
about 10 minutes to project seven
called the project seven this is one of
the palace
and here everything
and my life completely changed changed
to
in a bad way in a really bad way
but anybody else if he didn't
come from multi-family for him as wow
or everything you know an ib slave for
him is no problem how he treated me but
i'm not a slave i'm born free man and
you know sometimes even i don't listen
to my dad because
this is me but
he said look all these people around
here
is your now they look after you they do
everything for you
and this and that
go have a shower they bring me some nice
shower you know this is a palace one and
everything clean nice you know the
perfume is here is this thing
i have my shower they've shown me my
room it's really big beard and
everything is luxury
and they left me a few days there
tofu top drink top everything i wasn't
at the time
drinking alcohol even i didn't
you know let's have a smoker
about a week less than a week
people come i don't know who they are
but they don't look like iraqi
they start seeing a lot of
strep please what you mean strip
please everything my weight
my height teeth color
skin all that has been checked
i write it down i was short of
shorter you know of about three
centimeter three and a half centimeter
oh there you go he's very tall he's very
tall
that means you're also very tall you're
also
tall i am tall yeah yeah
uh but not same are they
this between us like
they checked everything was
even the voice very very close you know
even
even the doctor they say how this
happened
you know my age i am just four years
older of all day he born 14 i born 14th
of june
64. he born 18th of june 64.
you know i can't be more concerned
wait wait wait you guys are four days
apart from your birthday
yes i am older from four days
wow and they start checking and
everything
uh they say the height you know after a
few days the height
got to be sold you know have a high
shoes they put at the time
a general he was my mate you know just
in the bed he don't be with me he
training me
every single thing you know showing me
videos
showing me this show me that
but the training at the time does not
start
till they
did my teeth my front teeth all has been
changed
because although he have teeth forward
they make it exactly like him the gap
between the teeth all that sorted
was the chain they did the operation i
have a beard you can see it
as open the chin something
[Music]
they drilled i i did all these
operations when i
come out to the west i took everything
out
and after that i have a break
and really the bad suffering starts